ils sont 2 159 dans les yvelines 36 dans
les hauts-de-seine les maires des deux
départements avaient rendez vous pour la
première fois ensemble aux universités
des mairies des ateliers des tables
rondes organisées pour les élus
municipaux avec notamment des
partenaires d'autres collectivités
et tout à fait la stran nécessaire pour
que nous les maires puissent travailler
en bonne intelligence et avec cette
reconnaissance de la tente de la
population
le préfet nous avons si le contexte est
difficile les communes peuvent
bénéficier des devenant des
intercommunalités des départements des
régions et de l'état à travers les
services déconcentrés des aides sur le
vélo des aides sur les transports
propres des aides sur le verdissement de
la ville des aides sur le patrimoine
avec un bonus de 200 mille euros pour
tous les villages qui ont des besoins de
rénovation de patrimoine je n'oppose pas
la nécessaire décentralisation et son
approfondissement à un état qui soit
renforcée sur le territoire antagonisent
et les uns les autres n'a pas de sens
nous avons besoin les uns des autres des
partenaires privés présente du secteur
de l'immobilier des travaux publics ou
du transport avec de curieuses
découvertes comme le gouvernail un
mélange entre la boussole et la carte un
moyen d'information pour se déplacer et
valoriser le patrimoine d'une commune
une idée de la start-up bug lancé il ya
moins d'un an
je veux par exemple aller sur le stand
de la sncf je sais pas où ce qu'on le
sent la sncm donc j'ai juste à chercher
à la lettre s sncf qui sont en secteur 3
donc je prends un gouvernail je tourne
avec lui
positionne du secteur 3 devant moi et
voilà je vois immédiatement sncf voilà
je me suis physiquement et mentalement
face à ma destination
cette solution pourrait apparaître
prochainement dans les rues yvelinoise